à première vue la famille du g20
pourrait sembler unis mais à première
vue seulement ordre alphabétique des
pays oblige les leaders du canada et de
la chine sont assis côte à côte mais
devant les caméras pendant de longues
minutes
leurs regards ne se croisent pas il
semble même carrément signoret alors que
justin trudeau a bien pris soin de
saluer son voisin brésilienne le
président d'extrême droite djerbal sonar
ou justin trudeau et xi jingping ont
tout de même eu de brefs d'interaction
aujourd'hui comme cette poignée de main
le bureau du premier ministre qualifie
ces échanges de constructif mais
clairement pour le président chinois
le courant passe mieux avec d'autres
leaders justin trudeau compte justement
sur ses alliés pour dénoncer la
détention en chine des canadiens michael
pieper emma covering leur cas a été
soulevé dans une rencontre avec des
leaders européens et il ya beaucoup de
pays dans le monde qui partagent notre
opinion que c'est important de dire que
les détentions arbitraires ne sont pas
une bonne voie pour les relations
internationales entre les pays cela fait
des mois que le gouvernement trudeau
sollicite des appuis sur la scène
internationale ils misent sur le fait
que la chine va finir par en avoir assez
de se faire sermonner en public comme en
privé mais jusqu'ici difficile de voir
les résultats concrets de cette
stratégie
en plus de la détention des deux michael
la chine a suspendu ses importations de
viande canadienne est considérablement
restreint celle de canola christopher
lane persiste et signe
les déclarations d'un puits d'allier
compte selon elle et les déclarations
que nos alliés en fait en public à les
conversations qu'ils ont eue en privé
sans très important une signal important
pour le monde pour la chine que nous
avons appris au delà des brèves
interactions dont on sait encore peu de
choses entre justin trudeau et xi
jingping le gouvernement compte sur
l'appui de donnant aux hommes qui a
promis de faire tout ce qu'il peut pour
le canada mais l'équipe trudeau n'attend
pas l'issue de la rencontre de demain
entre les présidents américain et
chinois pour indiquer qu'elle ne
cherchera pas envenimer les tensions
avec la chine
mais ne reculera pas non plus ici
madeleine blé morin radio-canada osaka
au japon